[Musik]
wer hätte das gedacht
ja hallo meine lieben heute gibt es eine
bake rezepte machen bananen schnitten
und weil ich weiß dass jemand war
einfach keine zeit haben in der ofen
kalt bleiben soll habe ich mir heute was
richtig einfach ist für euch überlegt
was aber sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr lecker
ist weil banane in kombination mit creme
und kekse und schokolade ist einfach
immer lecker und hier habe ich schon die
zutaten sehr überschaubar wir schwenken
mal direkt über wir brauchen natürlich
bananen
hier habe ich kalte schlagsahne frisch
aus dem kühlschrank außerdem gespannt da
könnt ihr auch saure sahne verwenden
vanille extrakt zucker vanille pudding
pulver und milch übrigens ist es heute
eine premiere denn nicht das erste mal
puddingpulver in meinen videos ihr wisst
ja dass man das ja das ist einfach
fertig problem ja ich kann auch schon
gewundert als ich die packung rausgeholt
aber müsst ihr euch vorstellen das ist
eigentlich genau das gleiche wie
speisestärke nur dass da ein bisschen
vanille aroma dabei ist und so müsst ihr
eine farbpulver hat damit wie vanille
pudding aussieht finde ich persönlich
gar nicht schlimm ich habe absolut
nichts dagegen aber ich habe halt immer
speisestärke da und macht mir das nur
mit eigelb selber aber dann wüsstet ihr
ja nicht wofür das eiweiß verwenden
sollte also meistens weiß man das nicht
deswegen benutze ich dass heute der
einfachheit halber soll jetzt gebe ich
zu allererst milch in einem topf der
topf ist noch aus und rühre da das
vanillepudding pulver und den zucker 1
und damit wir noch intensiveren
vanillegeschmack haben gebe ich jetzt
hier vanille extrakt mit dazu ich habe
letztens übrigens auch schon mal probe
gebacken
das heißt gepackt und dann gesagt nicht
wirklich und da war mir einfach der
vanille geschmack zu wenig und ich bin
generell der meinung wenn man einmal
richtig weil hinter extrakt probierten
gegessen hat dann findet man alles
andere ist einfach zu wenig vanille
deshalb gebe ich jetzt noch ordentlich
rein so einen guten teelöffel oder 2 und
jetzt ruhig das krönchen frei und dann
wird der held erst eingeschaltet
[Musik]
den vanillepudding ganz einfach
aufkochen lassen so schön ein
und ich habe bewusst nicht so viel milch
genommen wie es verlangt wird denn für
drei packungen braucht man ja eigentlich
eineinhalb liter milch
ich habe das bewusst reduziert auf 900
milliliter damit er schön dick wird
und jetzt können wir in den noch heißen
pudding unseren stand ein
also das ist jetzt kein problem dass
hier noch ein zugleich die sahne darf
aber erst eingeführt werden wenn das
alles schön kalt ist
und jetzt wird der pudding an der
oberfläche mit folie abgedeckt dann
bildet sich auch keine haut macht ja
schön auskühlen und in der zwischenzeit
könnt ihr aber schon mal die sahne steif
schlagen und im kühlschrank lagern
[Musik]
der pudding ist schön ausgekühlt und
jetzt mache ich weiter mit der
schlagsahne
sie hatte ich übrigens nicht
zwischenzeit im kühlschrank dann hieß es
ganz ganz wichtig dass die sahne ganz
kalt ist und das auch wenn ihr zum
beispiel handlung gerät verwendet dass
hier die aufsätze auch nicht warm sind
an der mal passieren irgendwie nach dem
spülen oder so und jetzt schlage ich das
auf und lasst doch noch ein bisschen
sahne fest einen riesen weil bei dem
wetter kann das sein dass die sache dann
an zu schmelzen
[Musik]
meine dann ist es schön steif geschlagen
und ich habe mir schon ein bisschen mehr
steif geschlagen als ich für die creme
braucht denn ich möchte gleich für die
deko auch noch ein paar seine tochter
haben und jetzt nehme ich mir mein
handrührgerät so wie es ist geht damit
einmal in unserem pudding rein und
schlag ist auch noch mal so ein bisschen
auf damit sich das auflockert
[Musik]
nachdem wir den vanillepudding dann so
ein bis zwei minuten lang schon
aufgeschlagen habt ihr wieder
geschmeidig und dann könnt ihr die
hälfte der saane unteren das habe ich ja
hier schon gemacht und als dieses
brauchen wir noch irgendwas festes und
da habe ich mich jetzt für butterkekse
entschieden
ihr könnt jetzt natürlich auch keks
nehmen die im müll cacau zum beispiel
oder ganz spezielle kekse und wichtig
ist dass wir sie nicht ganz klein machen
sondern so ungefähr viertel oder fünftel
und dann geben wir die ganz großen mit
in die creme und heben das unter
[Musik]
jetzt ist unsere creme komplett fertig
und ich habe hier schon was bereit
gelegt nämlich meinen ba krampe schreibe
ich euch in die infobox soviel
zentimeter das sind damit ihr euch so
ungefähr vorstellen können wie groß das
ganze wird ihr könnt natürlich auch
leicht variieren dass es gar kein
problem
und als nächstes gebe ich die hälfte der
creme einmal rein streicht es glatt und
dann gebe ich bananen drüber
[Musik]
wir gucken jetzt schön glatt gestrichen
und als nächstes gebe ich freue mich
kuvertüre zusammen mit butter in die
mikrowelle niedrigste wert seit circa
zwei minuten dann komme ich zurück und
dann machen wir zusammen die glasur
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das noch einmal ganz kurz
zum kühlen in den kühlschrank gegeben
nur damit jetzt die oberste schicht
festwirt und jetzt will ich mir einen
tortenring messer oder ihnen durch eine
winkel palette hauptsache irgendwas dünn
ist und entfernt hier den tortenring und
back raum eigentlich
[Musik]
und wenn ihr jetzt auch lust habt auf
die bananen schnitten dann unbedingt
nachmachen die genauen mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch wie immer unten in der
infobox schnellen screenshot machen
einkaufen gehen und nach machen und dann
freue ich mich natürlich über eure fotos
mit dem hashtag es geht schon auf
instagram das heißt sie immer so fleißig
und das freut mich auch total
hinterlasst dem video gerne einen daumen
nach oben einen kommentar und abonniert
main kanal kostenlos dann verpasst ja
auch nichts mehr
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten video schüsse lieben
[Musik]